six young people from five nations with
great expectations summers Somalia
Kosovo mo not edit reiha-sama junior
Majid Syria lesson 1 learning German the
whole class struggles with the three
different prepositions today's language
quiz is more than just a game
because else's plan to be a nurse or
hymen odds dream of becoming a social
worker can only come true once they can
master the language Ahmed is 16 he tells
me how he travelled all the way from
Syria with his older brother
his parents expect him to find a way to
bring the whole family here it's not
easy for him to talk about what he left
behind love and you can't walk in the
street in Syria because somebody can't
just come and poof shoot you dead just
like that suit for this dish we have to
get out of there I just want my parents
to come here to work and to play
football
his friend Majid once that too he made
his way along the Balkan route all on
his own now here it's hard to stay in
touch with his family another salon I
would like to hear my parents voices
again but the internet in Aleppo is too
weak I can only message them on whatsapp
and viber from the messages I get they
are not doing that well by effective
Nikita
it's impossible to leave the fear for
their loved ones outside the classroom
where these young migrants are expected
to learn new skills take charge of
building their future here few are short
of motivation school means happiness to
me and asked if she went to school in
Eritrea she says only four years here
they are surrounded by teachers who
focus on their potential regardless of
whether they will be allowed to stay in
the end during break time the
headmistress tells me of her concern
that the enthusiasm for migrants may
begin to wane